sapevo
forza pippo state bene allora allora e
oggi
oggi vorrei iniziare all'inizio alle
isole show non è stata una delle serie
più powers del mio canale da una vita
che non lo gioco è difficile è un horror
fa paura
quindi penso abbia tutte le carte in
regola prezzo sul mio canale
e questa la prima live di serale che
faccio
vi ricordo anzi adesso lo cambia
descrizione le live tutti i lunedì sera
dalle 9 alle 11 e mezza e tutti i
giovedì sera dalle 9 alle 11 mento
quindi la live di domenica l'ho presa e
l'ho presa e l'ho spezzata in due
lunedì sera e giovedì sera è il sia
lunedì che giovedì esce il video di
giornata normale quindi abbiamo
guadagnato due video anzi sì abbiamo
tagliato torino
avete guadagnato live tutti i lunedì e
giovedì sera dalle 21 alle 23 e 30 in
realtà ragazzi devo capire ancora se
cambiarla questa cosa cs fare 21 e 30
mezzanotte o 21 23 32 ore e mezza di
live devo capire quale meglio secondo
salto vediamo vediamo come va
facciamo d'accordo oggi al in isole show
episodio pur ovviamente non l'hai prima
né sul canale come sempre
ciò detto news
ciao boy ciao allora andò a parigi mi
ecciti grazie 0
ciao lido dopo guardo il tuo canale va
bene
partiamo 3 1 lasko
9 spacca oggi 9 spaccate fantastico
siete
[Musica]
mica era perfetto sincrono la mia a kami
un fischio incredibile non erano nè l'ha
fatto apposta
wow grazie delrio nico grazie francesca
mazza o che è successo ciao sono davvero
felice che tu sia nella mia vita perché
nei momenti più brutti tu mi fai sempre
ridere tesoro grazie davvero
apprezzo un sacco davvero molto wow
molto wow
sono lusingato grazie grazie cristina
grazie alessandro grazi clip partiamo
allora e come vi ho detto io non ci
gioco da mille anni
qui non so non mi ricordo niente però
vediamo come va insomma bene
[Musica]
ok
raga io sapete che non mi ricordo niente
di questo non mi ricordo nulla
grazie andrea alla donazione grazia le
porca [ __ ] nnnn
grazie al e madonna che fai ti senti se
quei tempi di geometra dash grazie
magari lo riporto se hai voglia se pero
il dici tu lo faccio
grazie al cielo aperto grazie ma spowers
bomber e grazie serena sei bellissima
che cos'è modalità sopravvivenza
non lo so facciamo faremo poi alle isole
shawn ryan non mi dico io si sono così
che i salvataggi ci sono care salvataggi
come primo gennaio 7 gennaio 2015 7
gennaio 2000 e qui sono passati 4
fottutissimi anni cioè io sta cosa che
ci sono i suoi salvataggi nei giochi
rimasti non la capirò mai bellissimo
difficoltà media aveva iniziato a litro
si visibilissimo così almeno vediamo un
po tutti
che bello sono gasato per sta roba raga
è da una vita che non facciano
interaction da quattro anni quasi esatti
sgobba france
ciò anche oggi la bottiglia di acqua
sempre
[Musica]
perché il cane si morde la coda perché
lista in cui lo complimenti una battuta
che mi segnerò un'alta foro nel veicolo
spaziale commerciale nostromo da parte
del terzo ufficio stroma è passato da
fare il dono a fare le navi spaziali
componente un minimo peggio che in
[Musica]
lambert parker brands
ash e il comandante dallas sono morti
[Musica]
carico e nave sono distrutti
dovrai giungere alla frontiera tra sei
settimane si sono fortunata la
sorveglianza mi porterà in salvo
parla ripley ha già ripley si chiama
unica superstite del nostromo
passo e chiudo
[Musica]
paga preparatevi che questo è una bestia
sto gioco è una bestia è veramente una
bestia grazie parkour go pro grazie
lorenzo grazie francesco grazie giuseppe
matteo thank you for the nation
ecco questo è prima sono samuel il
lavoro per la compagnia tratta di tua
madre
crediamo di averla trovata amanda a
mandarli e poi sono una bella gnocca mi
ero diventi gallo poi sociale la nesi
dora ha recuperato la scatola nera che
proviene probabilmente dallo strato ora
gumy dovete dare una mano è se non mi
date una mano io mi inc ricco nei punti
quindi datemi una fottutissima mano ok
non come l'hiv stringendo e della mia
mano vera l'anno ok la stazione s vasto
di materiale riservato e la compagnia
vuole farla ritirare il prima possibile
sebastopol fa da deposito forniture
nella regione un porto franco gestito so
cos'è un porto franco
anch'io portò frana in tutto organizzato
mio amico non c'è una nave corriera
chiamata torrens che andrà alla stazione
fra due giorni ci recheremo lì sì io è
un altro dirigente e tu se vorrai quanti
cazzata sta tipa quanto incazzata da una
miller loardi da solo questo caso ho
fatto le mie ricerche quanto gnocca
anche se vogliamo proprio perché stai
lavorando nella regione in cui è
scomparsa tua madre la cerchi ancora
vero
mister non morire che non c'è lei angoli
2 sulla torre
se vuoi venire forse ciò di cui hai
bisogno
sì non vedo l'ora che un alieno mi
stupri l'anno ci sia voglia buona gara
come contenta grande andiamo a fare
festa sul sulla nave spaziale caso è
quello che voglio e mi piace quando
quando gli alieni partecipano alle feste
porca vacca se mi piace mamma mia oh che
bello che bello
sempre meglio di sono nuda
va bene signori siamo partiti va bene
così tasti movimento per favore a celi
login
queste facebook scheda di siamo passati
dallo sba le schede nord esplora la
torrents siamo nella torrens fernando
fernando torres devo capire dove stiamo
andando
questa è la vita e la nave è quella
normale
obiettivo aggiornato vestiti mi sembra
ovvio che almeno questo lo devo fare
dicevo prima grazie francesco per la
nazione e super di mi dicevo non mi
ricordo nulla
salve senonché neanche dove sono i
vestiti sono non mi guardare solo nudo
non ricordare sono un lontano ricordo
non mi guardare guarda guardarmi
molto simile pervertito schifoso segue
un modello più avanzato ma con
specifiche figli ha svolto compiti da
ingegneri sulla di conquista certo non
sono cagato di striscio mi serve di mi
servirà per i vestiti i vestiti quelli
che metti addosso perché la gente non ti
guarda nuda
non è che non ha seguito sono nuda vi
servono vestiti grazie gentile non mi
guardare sono dati proprio niente di
buono
anche io stiamo per essere uccisi da una
manina alien regolarmente ci si abitua
non faccio lunghi viaggi così spesso
molti dirigenti ne sono qui io come in
quella prova perché motore di caffè
sono sorpresa che la uil andrew tania
piacevoli infatti qui la perdita del
nostro amore del suo carico è costata
molto alla causa sta roba qua importante
che scopriamo cosa è successo
sono questi sono semplicemente cosi ho
realizzato che tua madre è sparito da 15
anni può già trovare oggetti buono
questa cosa buona
senti sai dove si dice di spara cagate
amici dove sono investiti per cortesia i
vestiti quelli che ti metti addosso per
non prendere freddo quelli obiettivo
aggiornato parla con te e lei taylor ma
sono scemo io scusa milano allora parla
con me a vestiti vestiti stavano la lei
e taylor mongoloide riflettere comunque
vestiti stanno qua in un nuovo visto che
c'era la mappa va bene ovviamente per
per affrontare a lia bisogna avere i
vestiti io non mi ricordo ma mi pare che
questa non è la nave quella di aliano
ovviamente qua ci stiamo semplicemente
andando sulla nave che mi pare che si
chiami andromeda come si chiama
quindi noi andiamo non aver capito tutto
ci dobbiamo arrivare quindi questa non è
una vera nave easing non c'è niente qua
ok vestiti wright con chi devo parlare
con te chavo davanti taylor bobo è tra
l'altro nomi cordova dove si salvano le
partite comunque ragazzi non vedo l'ora
di incontrarlo quello monet quella alien
carino
non so quanto ci avevo messo di mi pare
durasse dieci ore quindi forse in
quattro live e lo finisco però che poi
adesso ancora si è la di là mi hanno
parlato già tullio pinelli per solo
potrebbe averla turbata ciao matteo
martina grazie mille
ci arriveremo prima o poi installate
destra va beh posso cosa dobbiamo fare
qua ma non c'è un obiettivo
no mi chiama dava dottor ancora indietro
non c'è un obiettivo tipo fisso che dice
che cosa devo fare sempre ma perché ogni
tanto mi perdo i film di stasera e altri
due cafè parte grazie zio noi gentile me
li faccio dopo i due caffè comunque
parlavo i tipi raga mi mi dispiace la
nave iniziale è una palla tranne la tipa
io ero veramente [ __ ] prima che che mi
vestissi ve lo ricordate e minchia se me
lo ricordo io ho fatto veramente una se
mi dicono ha capito il tipo pensate ci
ho fatto una se tra l'altro quando ho
iniziato questo gioco qua mi ero appena
trasferito nella nuova casa cioè quella
vecchia
la roba allucinante vieni parlami
parlami di me cosa vuoi lo facessi il
move in ritardo veli per solo potrebbe
averla turbata già parlato sembra
nervosa non l'avevo notato è una
dirigente abile comunque dovrebbe essere
in grado di aiutarci con eventuali
questioni legate
parla con samaras ok parliamo di nuovo
di nuovo con taylor a sebastopoli si
chiamava vai sul ponte per aver vissuto
va bene se io non mi ricordo poi però
tra l'altro come cia ricominciano
entrare nell'altra nave ball taylor è
sparita il ponte sta qua ciao france
ciao farsi notare da te grazie zio
all'onore e tutto mio
grazie mille di farmi ridere ogni giorno
prego grazie a te vaccino anche lei
immaginava che bella scorta zia ci
vestiamo un po meglio quando andiamo
nello spazio ai sul ponte previsto
nessuno figo che figo sto gioco è
veramente fatto bene stiamo attaccando
so che il tuo contatto e l'ufficiale
pesanti manderò sebastopol e organizza
il bel delle donne
mi dite dove donna forse mi ricordo cosa
succede adesso
e non è una cosa bella ma che ne sta
parlando azioni di presentano avete i
vostri documenti con le istruzioni si è
perciò la carta d'identità al metodo
prendi documento
è equa preso una madonna non mi dico
ecco questa è la questa la nave di
aliano hanno perso tutti contano per la
passerà sui monitor minchia che figata
situazione se basta giuro
ci sono dei danni sì sembra di sì prendi
il 74 stringi pensavo loud ingranaggio
sembra di 74 boh non possa portarci la
torres come genitore sinclair matricola
n 77 60 dobbiamo parlare con il capitano
della torres abbiamo tre passeggeri
sotto contratto della weiland aiuta né a
bordo ci risulta che siete in possesso
della scatola nera del nostromo
chiediamo il permesso immediato di
trasferire i passeggeri sulla stazione
passo
pronto marshall giorno dio io fare il
dietrofront subito gira al volante ciao
ale non mi sono messo dietro si rilassi
e vi erano questo pro 15 inserito una
radio nella tuta di sangue ciao
all'atari e il bacino o malato la cena
ha proseguito la livecast sceglie le 9
voluti ti volti grazie però in bocca al
lupo bella ciao roberto un bacione ai
all 11 o cablati bacino con giorgio
cambini passeggiate nello spazio è
l'unica opzione
c'è quindi per arrivare in un'altra
stazione spaziale tu cosa fai ti metti
la tuta e sci come quando vai al parco
esci ti butti sul sull'altra stazione
c'è un esempio
redazione
resta dietro a d m anche tu samuel
certo il tipo non è contento per niente
ceche 2.9 gano fra i mai non lo farei
mai mai se sbagli mira se nel gene q
benissimo stiamo andando da dio tutti a
posto tutto bene tutto bene fuochi
d'artificio un call come a napoli il
casinò fuochi
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] questa ma ricordo di
quest'anno
[Musica]
sono morti tutti permesso cosa speravate
di fare di lanciarvi di entrare nella
porta ho fatte
e stato divertente lui facciamo se
volete lo rifacciamo da amy mi sembra un
buon modo per passare il venerdì le
linee il gioco e venerdì
[Musica]
ma a proposito di napoli ci sei mai
stato io voglio spettacolare immagine ad
ios installativa potresti potessi
vibrerà potresti ci siamo ma questo è un
horror
r no stiamo giocando a cooking mama
spendo smetta che non arriva il partito
di cina però cerca aiuto
sì mi vorrei togliere sta a fare posso
io devo cercare aiuto io che sono
arrivato qua per aiutare gli altri
va bene cambiati io sono arrivato per
avvisare gli altri arrivo cerca aiuto
bene bene se mai stato a dubai
no
dove vado qua e allegra questi per
salvare me lo ricordavo sovrascrive
salvataggi anche se l'avevo già finito
chi non andrebbe sono navi spaziali
distrutta con una tazza di terna me lo
chiedo anch'io
minchia che allegro suo posto meno male
porco demonio non primari erano quanto è
fatto bene il suo gioco lega
sono passati 4 fottutissimi anni 4 mamma
mia che brutta storia
il tempo vola
io non ci credo che sono parte non
possono essere passati quattro anni
cazzo credibile di kwa kie pericolo
chiusa d'aria l'emergenza no di qua sono
arrivato che deficente mi sono perso in
tre metri quadri
andiamo a senso a meno che non debba
andare dove c'era il fuoco però la vedo
dura come faccio a sorpresa meno che non
serva un estintore
e scriviamo 5 giamo a noi c'è un gancio
punto è vero che ci sono i condotti sto
gioco
minchia aver dimenticato il condotto
mamma mia
anche meglio di cooking mama certo
dipende se cucina reali e saporito
mi raccomando è semi incarto in qualche
pezzo aiutatemi ragazzi seguite i walk
through che io vi chiedo
romeo
agi e mangiato fagioli mi piace delle
bombe al mattino che vabbè figura non
avevo dubbi tranquilla non avevo dubbi
i dubbi non ce li avevo allegria
se è bello sono proprio contento di
essere qua invece di essere da qualsiasi
altra parte nel mondo c'era la luce
mentario razzo che cosa fa rima razzo
non mi serve una luce quelle cose che
punti in giro per vedere meglio quella
magari la persona te la prendi quando
vai e son qualcuno sapeva
sei sempre come lavorare il giorno
perché che fa i graffiti su una nave
soprattutto perché c'è una bomboletta
spray per fare i graffiti su una nave un
pezzo di metallo ani si potenziano le
armi se non mi ricordavo
ciao trio grazie per la donazione
ciao ale ti seguo ancora dei primi video
this lander mense un grande grazie zio
primo video di svenderlo 2012 2012 non è
finito il mondo ma ho iniziato
ho iniziato a fare video io che ha più o
meno la stessa cosa perché c'è una radio
se nessuno
se mi salta in faccia a qualcuno io me
ne vado cambio gioco forgotten fa vj usa
questi terminali per aggiornare la mappa
delle con le aree che senso ha lo fa
l'elettricista
ecco cos'è che serve star europa
non ho capito trovo bene ok per
aggiornare la mappa questa qualcomm che
premo che sia per tutto va bene ma paga
stiamo arrivando in pezzi veramente
brutti cioè io lo dico audio pubblica
spostato le scuole giusta roba non leggo
e perdonatemi lega pro che palle
ripristino la corrente nell'area
questa si apre è permesso molto gentile
pollo anno apollo c'è scritto va bene
ocio che si muore molto bene la
smettiamo di muovere tutto grazie ci
sono i sopravvissuti che uccidono i
sopravvissuti non mi cade mongoloidi
jean casinò vivere qua sevastopol mi
dimeno dimenticato che si chiamava sta
roba
lo devo andare urko demonio
poi con corno e stage enna era ancora
meglio
le urla un po un po di più
tipo sui balconi brand pina sono qua ci
dicono che devo andare dove vado a cena
però la partita cejas ambientazione
veramente horror figurati il resto è
prendilo grazie sarà molto gentile
grazie samu anche tu
se invece a funzionare il costo per
cabinato come acceso adesso si aprono le
porte bene io entro con una veemenza che
fa poco tanto chissenefrega faccio io
paura a dalian non mi ricordo se ci sono
le aree di qua c'è in questo lo so che
ci sono un amico dove sony dove la trovo
la mia prima arma ci sono entrato senza
torcia senza niente senza dire così come
mamma mi ha fatto nudo
devo fare il giro andranno un'altra
porta sì che dio ti aiuti non avrai
bisogno sì sì maledizione alla vita si
tra tutti i giochi io potevo iniziare
proprio questo ogni testo va bè ragazzi
siate con me siete in 15.000 a tutti
contrari e non fuori di sputargli in
faccia secondo me lo buttiamo giù
portello bloccato sono contento qualcuno
dice che porto ho sbloccato dove devo
andare a lato resta cioè che non cerca
di contattare alla stazione di partenza
posso dire che lo usano indietro torna
indietro sono sto facendo giusto di
tenore
immagino di sì comunque tu
maledizione
ho attivato mikado ti chiedevo cosa qua
non fa niente va bene questo che abbiamo
anche un mi sa che si è sbloccata una
porta quella a cevo questa che sia
aperta bene lui bueno forse store mano
forse non sia per terra già aperto ci
sono delle della colla a cosa serve
della colla spiegami inserire codice di
accesso water fac
ma va ci sarà scritto la sopra
immaginano a cagliari ciao mi chiamo
grazie mi da cagliari share alle 21 ciao
chiara grazie al sì sì mi ricordo che il
nome in elfico ciao michele devo leggere
il codice codici si era scritto qua no
no no no
e vai su non mi fa selezionare secondo
me non ci sono scritte qui dove c'è
scritto il codice rega 0 17 02
boh mi state mettendo un miliardo di
cose devi andare a ok ok allora i
condotti bene pensa pensavo pensavo di
venderla grazie meno non fa niente la
vita è più bella se sei elettrizzata
dicevo no ho sbagliato devo andare in un
condotto aggiusta temi sempre queste
cose qua perché se no magari sto fermo
in un punto che non c'è l'editing quindi
non posso tagliare i punti dove sto
fermo tanto no però almeno ci siete voi
che mi suggerite più o meno dove sto
sbagliando quindi da una parte c'è una
negatività dall'altra c'è la positività
quindi voi potete darmi una mano e date
mela tipo adesso mi ha detto rich in un
condotto però da temi spesso una mano se
non mi perdo dove sto condotto guarisca
e condotto guarisi sa che qua sotto
dalla botta che si trovano stanza dove
sabato vediamo se avete detto una cagata
o meno ma è vero let's go my friends
grazie raga supergentile diamo è
purtroppo non so
integrante può che piacere queste uguali
questo cade a pezzi ma minchia che sei
proprio un'osservatrice complimenti
grazie avermelo detto no perché non ci
sarei mai arrivato
io non posso saltare in soli o con chi
non salgo
cioè io non posso saltare ricordatevelo
where are the post dove dove doveva
ancora non si è visto aliena e mi sto
già prendendo male c'è pure [ __ ] di
tua sorella morta se guardo la chat non
mi devi far spaventare mi stavo
concentrando chi è stato ma un colloide
dove lo va a cagare va forse era cos'era
quella roba lì grazie patrizia però dono
se stavo leggendo facendo cose non mi
distrarre cristo
mi chiami sono cattivi si misura stato
orribile
e non mi dicono che sono ok madonna è
vero che questione di riprese di the vip
che le colpe e chiede di porco come che
lo trovo incredible comico non ha capito
ok ma non si passa salve
lì c'è un tizio morto vabbè
facciamo conto oltre che si morti no
torcia al plasma a è vero che alcune
cose devi tipo devi inforcare la porta a
fare cose strane
ciao ciao ale ciao elisa grazie mille
dall'anziana thank you thank you very
much
io ottengo insomma si può entrare sia a
sinistra che a destra che va bene niente
torna indietro immagino che ci sia una
roba una porta c'è per però devo trovare
la piede di porco be wired dal piede di
porco anche il co demonio poi piede di
porco demonio che è più avanti deve
esserci resi da minchia è un quadro mi
sono pagato in mano visto un'ombra passa
per il portello principato ciao simply
mino cristo santo dovrebbe solo nei
sopravvissuti sono quello quello morto
mi sa che non è sopravvissuto quello
morto da sa che è morto credo è poi
magari mi sbaglio io però quello morto
forse mi sa che in orto no volevo solo
vedere se c'era qualcosa dentro non
nasconde amici dentro per
lui la madonnina è che la rinchiuso
nella stanza delle prove che nella
stanza alle prove c'è un piede di parità
me le prove dove l'assenza delle prove
dove la stanza delle problemi come si
chiama la stanza delle prove nella
stanza delle prove c'è un piede di porco
buono a sapersi visto che mi serve per
entrare nelle porte
questa è la stanza eccolo lì gli serve
quel coso che ha in mano mi serve questo
è chiusa mi serve ci sarà un condotto
c'è il condotto molto bene
15 di fare una mascotte su di te ciao
davide emanuele già batterista ciao
mascotte grazie alle donazioni una
mascotte di te va bene va bene
intanto sono già didimi una scalata
ciao david david dove settete salve
grazie
gentilissimo mio molto gentile staccati
brutto schifoso live mi serve questo
quello posso dare in testa alla gente
per caso fa vedere mai il piede di porco
non lo posso dare in testa alla gente
che peccato
come si fa togliere a sparare
sì semi dovevate far fare il meccanico
simula ritorno di ciò che prima
ciao rossella grazie mille
minchia posso aprire strutture da sola o
la chiave per qualsiasi cosa
praticamente di euro mentre le dighe vai
vai apri mai mona adesso devo andare se
non sbaglio questo cadaveri che avevo
capito tu stai ferma perché la gente è
un dito nel culo nei giochi horror
perché c'è alien
ci abbiamo un nemico in comune non basta
tranquillo abbiamo un nemico in comune
non ci ma cosa vuole ma rubate o piedi
di porco da dove arrivi replay
abbiategrasso
non ci sono navi buone notizie perché
qui non ce la passiamo bene c'è stata
un'esplosione ha fatto tremare tutto
ma l'oggetto
quello è l'ultimo dei nostri problemi ma
sì sì c'è qualcosa su questa stazione
non ci crederesti mai di che parli un
assassino
capisci raga mastrolindo sto qua
questo fare questo sgorga i tubi del
lavandino
come ti chiami lisco mastrolindo di axel
non è vero
menti stavo salendo apporto contro con
necchi e ne va
l'esplosione c'è separati e io ti a
trovarmi mi dai la pistola perché sembri
conoscere i polsi ma per chi è sempre un
altro bimbo era una risposta alla data
perché vivo aiuta perché voi che ti
aiuti perché sempre maggiori a me dite
scappi gli ingorghi devo contattare
nemmeno
grazie oggi sei fortunata domani 6
pelata così bene vorrei aprire la porta
d'ingresso raggiunge la stazione della
navetta come possiamo raggiungerla
attraverso l'area di carta ma stai
attenta che quel posto ci siamo spesso
la mente uguale comunque una storia ma
non solo per la pelata proprio per
investito guardalo ora che faccia forza
eri tu che mi seguì di allora
dovevo tenermi a distanza qui non si
vuole ovviamente va bene cosa resta di
centro c'è gente salve io sono lì lui e
mastro lindo siamo tranquilli sono solo
un paio di stronzi non c'è tempo da
perdere abbiamo già potete aiutarci non
ci serve il loro aiuto
ciao patrizia bianca e giulia e al cielo
bianca di corini né a tenerife la bionda
in spiaggia lo dovrei ricordare visto
quello che è scritto però no strano
incontro biondi in spiaggia a tenerife
non me ne ricordo scherza certo mi
ricordo bianca massimizzati ciao alle
mense e più sicuro così spero davvero
c'è la mia nave ci sono poi sono
arrivato qua con gli ovetti kinder
aspetta chiamo l'ascensore ascensore
stato fa e unipol ha fatto uno scatto
solo per l'ultimo metro questo qua dei
problemi
sto andando molto bene stranamente molto
adesso
chiediamo un pò sulla mia nave devo
sapere che sta succedendo e subito cazzo
prede sei un assassino un assassino che
vorrei
va bene lo smentì qui
allora ci seguono un botto ho sempre
pensato che se un ragazzo stava
simpatico devo dire che con i temi
l'acquisto ci sto crescendo grazie di
tutto un bacio a te miriam grazie mille
grazie david e grazie lorenzi ancora non
si è visto alien tra l'altro molto bene
sono contento di questo
muoviti sgorga landini penoso demonio
che già sta gente dovremmo cercare una
via d'uscita
ci sono vie d'uscita almeno saremo al
sicuro ma perché dobbiamo combattersi
tra di noi se c'è un alien mi devi stare
lontano mi dai fastidio stai vai via
parma incastrato nel muro pezzente ma
incastrato nel muro non posso muovere in
più che c'è lui fermo
segui axel nei condotti ma non è che mi
faccia impazzire si deve però tanto lui
se rimaniamo incastrati sgorgano davvero
sono bird
mi sono già scontrato con questi mi
piacciono e non capisco perché si devono
abbassare tra di loro
inter single gay con d'ordine cisco di
stamparli veloce futili la pistola spara
gli e vai avanti qualcuno e ho rifatto
lo stanno facendo
si chiama sopravvivenza deluso in
[ __ ]
ma se cala devo che grazie td di lardo
nero 2 euro un giorno successa di rende
ciao che la e tu vivi 15
i tifosi perché il mio maggiordomo in
ferie prendi quello sicura di sé video
the show non sappiamo quando ci
ricapiterà by settimana aspettando la
nave aspetta botte sono stato bravo
finora sono stato molto bravo
questo posto resta al buio molto ciao
giovanni tenchi fornendo nascere vieni
pure a monaco di baviera certo venire
guardate cosa ho lanciato bilbo lanciato
di bobo noso il coperchio del gelato ti
togli per cortesia tiro lanciare le cose
prendi la prova allora se non stai calmo
tg ti faccio crescere i capelli e ti
strappo 1 a 1
dove sta minchia di torcia dov'è eccola
axel indo certo la vita dai entra veloce
quanto tempo prevenute pepe ricaricato
ciò che f f
sto ricaricando non ovunque io una
torcia la dovrei avere a prescindere se
proprio proprio perché io entro nelle
navi spaziali le torce ci dovrebbero
essere di base controllo il condotto
dovrebbe essercene un altro qui intorno
condotto ricadere f per accendere o
spegnere della torcia ce n'è un altro pò
guardà questo ho trovato io vi vuole
quello che non serve a niente usata con
parsimonia ecco infatti le le pile le
pile si trovano in giro ma io non ho
capito come non ancora trovata neanche
mezzo avere una storia
io non ho incontrato mezza pila vabbè le
pile che troveremo e le useremo se se
siamo nella cassetta dagli una mazzata
qualcosa che in mano ma io gli avrei già
data ragazzi
ma cos'è sto cose qui in mano non ore e
mezzo a un petardo
ciao romina sei tu anni e lo so cazzo
guardi vai avanti che sto leggendo i
messaggi
ciao giulia oggi my father bomba aspetto
prossimo visto che con ansia tranquilla
carica presto giovedì giovani mesi fa
giovedì e lunedì e giovedì escono le
serie la mattina che gli episodi pari e
la sera live quindi l'episodio
dell'altra serie quindi una serie lie e
una serie non in live giuria dietro la
torrents sì sì ho sentito qualcosa
certi post uscire insieme
vabbè ripeto li vedo non li vedo cosa
vuoi che in eta urlare buon compleanno
capito però desistere il casms of the
line filo nel culo
te lo giuro il razzo serva fare luce va
bene lo usiamo andiamo di quadri ogni
caso non sembrava aperta andiamo andiamo
andiamo seguiamoli tranquillo tran qui
si sta avvicinando il momento al il misa
sono se non sto camminando sparito che
succede
gli occhi aperti ma per chi sparano per
chi sfogliamo tra di noi che siamo
esseri umani perché
gianni modello in fondo
proviamo un diversivo il generatore se
saltasse dovrebbero andare altro è lui
che sta parlando mi sembra che stia
parlando da dall'altra parte della
stanza macchina va bene
cerca un modo per dire che jacob e per
che cosa cazzo vorresti dire lei è stato
con me per tutto il tempo a colla
punizioni medicinali se non è stato uno
di noi avevamo ragione
qualcuno è stato qui non va bene però
che non si sta facendo abbastanza piano
è solo il commesso di un negozio solo
dicendo
piantatela di parlare molto legato su
facebook
il catania
genera donna è morta questo è il
generatore cristo cristo cristo sono
messo dietro non so mai senso fatto una
buona scelta
grazie per il tuo impegno nel portare
live ma figurati zio un piacere
devi spingere i the forest certo e non
il live però fare un episodio apposta
che uscirà mito costo di novembre
dovrebbe non vorrei una cagata di per il
28 e scelte foresta fino dedicato cristo
di dio non mi ha visto vuole farci non è
visto un ciclo e orba e orbo c'è la luce
che qua mi illuminamento siano mi vedo
l'interruttore per qualcun altro l'ha
visto abbiamo provato
sarebbe stato bellissimo così e poi si
gira che non mi vede cazzo ci ho creduto
un attuale ciò veramente creduto
tantissimo
che sfiga questo posto resta al buio
molto spesso una minchia che spalle
cerca di non restare senza batterie non
possiamo fare tipo che ci sono i check
point non si può salvare quel non si può
salvare nel mentre no dei poveri partire
da una rottura ogni volta torna indietro
vabbè anche perché ci metto una vita ad
arrivare lì incazzo si parte con le
batterie non l'avevo visto bene vai vai
vai vai veloce cech e parenti vari
partiti qua non c'erano di salvataggi
più vicini ma almeno adesso lo sapeva
almeno adesso lo so devo salvare spesso
se no sono da questa parte sorry
non sapevo non mi dico dopo grazie
organizza grazie nunzio mi sa che c'è
comunque c'era cassano batte di
cianobatteri ovunque sono orbo non ho
visto niente
ci sono sicuramente c'è un salvataggio
anche più avanti che non ho visto però
non mi ricordavo ragazzo
ho un bengala
sì lo so ragazzi il problema è che non
so come si apre ad inventare solo
modello un dettaglio vai vai apri apri
veloci
dai veloci e pelato maledizione quanto
tempo
minchia mastro che balle ti muovi come
mio nonno chiama veloce veloce cribbio
anche lagato mentre lo insulta qualcosa
raggiungere gli altri si lo so lo so vai
vai vai vai dai cazzo dai secondo me qua
c'è un eccolo il costo per salvare dove
era porco demonio eccolo guarda guarda
guarda dove era guarda guarda dove rai
mi sono fatto tutto sei volte
che palle ovviamente in tutti i punti
critici ti mettono in corso per salvare
e io non l'ho visto mongoloide è venato
di brazzers non certo tutto rispetto
e allora io vado al generale rifacciamo
va dal generatore ci vado anche senza
che lui si fermi chissenefrega
che succede
ci vado a prescindere e la rete vi ho
trovato
vicino a generatori c'è un condotto
dove mi si quando vedi è vero ma mica io
ragazzi non li vedi condotti per terra
non li vedo non vedo le botole per terra
non le vedono sono orbo grazie nunzio
grazie signor games grazie giuliano non
vedo io non vedo le botole non le vedo
per me non esistono ma io cosa devo fare
qua
apro e non vedo uscirei pure ma non vedo
siciliennes te vieni vieni vieni zio
vieni veloce veloce mi chiamo ramon e
scatta guardalo guardalo usain bolt è
diventato un fenomeno scappa con axel
mai avrei delle pretese un po più alte
io questo che non è proprio benissimo
non perché pelato è perché non è neanche
simpatico sì
non lo so marchio seguì filo questa roba
qua da sbloccare inodore nemmeno essere
qui sarei dovuto partire la settimana
scorsa
boh non ho capito se c'è qualcosa che
dobbiamo fare io in lui boh non c'ho
voglia di leggere sono pigro sono pigro
e pigro rimango apt fa qualcosa ci hanno
isolati che famo ho capito dobbiamo
attivare le due centraline contemporanea
vedi sapevo che dovevo farmi un blog di
questa tua spingi l'interruttore
pubblici pitt medico
devo seguire il filo ok vai pronta al
mio tre
ci hanno messo una vita occhio frate
frate
vabbè tanto non merita di vivere arrivo
arrivo salva bomba
minchia che porta fortissimo ma stai
calmissimo ma calmo c'è nel senso che
non ci stiamo sparando due cazzotti e
via una partita a poker mi chiamo 46 tra
aggira io correrei fortissimo dipendenti
carico a ricordi veloci veloci però
veloce minchia veloce
[Musica]
perché stava per uccidere me mi hai
salvato la vita è questione di
sopravvivenza
lo capisci se mai state scappando da
gente tipo che era dietro di voi
a parte che cola del sangue milione
brevi anche da lì a mi sa che qualche
c'è alien acsi signori mai date il
benvenuto allo zio
credo che sia questa è proprio lui
proprio lui che giocatore è
e se è entrato pure nel voto venete lui
fu fino grazie a riparazioni che sarà
quella roba alien alien è un cane
incrocio tra un maltese vorrei che io
dovrei andar via velocissimo prima che
quel tipo arrivi invece ogni veloce
velocissimo o cuoce della roba ma non è
un tornello
ce la farà arrivare secondo
però c'è appassionarli lavate in faccia
alla gente si sta roba arriva magari
quanto tempo quanto tempo per parti che
non l'ho salvato aver salvato era il
generatore quindi non vorrei morire dopo
non vorrei farlo
io vi ringrazio
dai veloce veloce minchia veloce
questa musica orribile dai zio veloce
porca vacca veloce ti ho detto veloce o
ci mette degli anni della loro non so
che dire ti ammiro molto e spero tu
possa continuare così
sempre a testa alta grazie big jim
bravis
grazie zio molto gentile scappa con asse
pensate che comunque mongoloide io devo
scappare
pensate come sono ridotto veloce vieni
qua schiacciato tasto entra nella porta
muori sono morto per niente porco
demonio dai dai mettiti dischi al sul
pulsante schiavo ho capito cribbio
che palle
al mio tre
[Musica]
dai dai veloci e tra l'altro che uno che
si traccia un altro che si dice [ __ ]
a chavez identificato gioielliere
arrivato grazie antonio grazie ma spa o
nuovo andare dietro di te non guarderò
mai i nati cioè il sergente quant'altro
è sparita prima mi seguiva mai sparita
veloce è cosa fa si blocca metà di
questo l'ho vista l'ho visto dai ora se
ci fosse il modo per salvare sarebbe
molto più carino ma non c'è chi ricorre
chiama l'ascensore nasconditi ma io
quando mi nascondo posso stare dietro le
cose che faccio piano bianca piano piano
piano minchia piano
nell'angolino e non
ma
perfetto tappeto quelle esattamente
quello che non doveva succedere
ragazze non mi metto qua non so dove
mettermi
mi metto qua giusto
ditemi se c'è un tutto dove mi devo
mettere di procedimento qua dove posso
mettermi scusate
prima è uscito è
no
si è aperta la porta avrà fatto casino
adesso lavorativa per le more della
porta
forse se scatto cervo minchia che ansia
madonna regalano mai avuto questa ansia
la mia vita chiudi ti chiudi ti chiudi
chiudi via via via via veloce
ho finito l'acqua alla gola secca
datevi dei calmanti delle siringhe
only skill e francesca tenco insomma ci
trova un ascensore non trovo la mia
voglia di vivere soprattutto fino a qui
tutto bene a noi lì dentro per vedere se
c'è della roba non le si nasconde dentro
la water park ricablaggio
no
non ho capito
ok quindi o aprì una roba o aprì un
altra va bene dai ho capito che cosa
minchia serve nei fili della trama ma
questa volta ritel e tutte e due ma che
vi frega ma che vi frega questo dove
sono arrivato va bene di qua fa salvo
salvo grazie a gesù cristo ovunque tu
vada a laglio anti troverà grazie
ragazzi siete fantastici mi voglio bene
ricordati di salvare essi essi minchia
che mi ricordo di salvare ne sono
accorto prima che se non salvo cielo nel
capra anzi ma che la metà bassa perché
c'è la gente ma perché la gente urla il
suo gioco che problemi avete no no no no
war sco demonio via macori
a casa la gente sbarra vista non ci
credo è chiusa e 4 ning e trovava
davanti i più acclamati in bocca ma
hanno ancora visto
sono andata bene si chiama mi ha sparato
e se n'è andata vabbè testa di culo lo
pensi di metallo via via via via via
devi andare a casa
abbiamo trattati posto di sassi che la
fiction aveva fatto la stella di
sicurezza che c'è questa se n'è andata
devi andartene tra 14 13 12 e devo
andare devo andarmene c'è scritto che me
ne devo andare cistite non c'è un
counter lì che cos'è quel camper
l'impedire cos'è quel counter lingua 4 3
2 1 che succede
me ne sono andato che è successo
così è successo perché c'era quel
counter devi andartene ora che andava in
un retro mi sono creato in mano
cos'è che era che è successo c'è gentili
a cristo
che cosa succede devi andartene perché
arrivano l'orco demonio ma visto va bene
la gente vede in suo gioco strano non
avremo scappa scappa ma che è un casino
pietracupa vedermi ma mi chiama io mi
accomazzo apposta boglione
dai dai si avvia secondo me ne devo
andare
devo andare da un'altra parte devo
tornare indietro e circuiti sono
distrutti nel proprio dai dai premio
logico ma c'è chi prova non ce l'ha
proprio ok quindi io torno indietro ha
detto sticazzi della gente da un drone
darei basta che ho preso sta roba da
torni a fatemi salvare possa salvare
perché non posso salvare attendere che
avremo a far funzionare papa leger
sistema instabile
vai pesci ma si dovrebbe essere chiuso
la porta di prima è aperta questa in
teoria teoria è quella lì
aperta
no bene bene far vedere sulla mappa
trovi tutti sono attese tra lasciarlo
andare lì e come faccio scusami orco
demonio che togli spranga semplicità
sbanca quella che mi portavo prima noi
che cambia niente
vabbè sprechiamo non è che devo chiamare
la navetta che se dubito che debba
formare la navetta adesso adesso mi fa
salvare molto bene mentre la portavi
davanti va bene ma ci entro
questa io mi ricordo che dovevo fare
ok that's di cose io non mi ricordo le
cose
ma
ma dopo questi pattugliano io devo
entrare forse di sopra
cosa cazzo conte monio che kakà mi sono
pagato non sono pagati simone sono
veramente cagato mi sono legatissimo e
niente di te ne deve andare non so o per
aver condotto provato l'altro provato
tutto mi sono veramente cagato e non so
cosa vedova provato andare un po
dovunque
ditemi voi dove vado quanto prima che
arrivo
eppure minchia dovrebbe essere qua o
apro questa
a regà aiuto al piano di sopra di sopra
come vado a far vedere arrivare poi
faccio arrivare di sopra ma devo andare
lì sopra che dai pro vandali solo con
ricordi sticazzi sticazzi da agenti
ficcarsi aiap
minchia devi salire le scale come le
salgo le scale
c'è una mappa da prendere sul monitor
[Musica]
devi salire le scale che qui ci salgo le
scale c'è gente ragazzi allora facciamo
così mi curo sicuro come sicuro non ci
si cura
questo è il razzo non avrò solo raso
implementare il suo miliardo di robe ho
preso gli ardori ho preso i messaggi
sarkozy apre l'inventario opzioni gioco
inventario q no quindi non non non non
si nun c'ho lì non c'è niente perso
tutto vabbè vabbè magari giuro e mi
vedono soldi che vista c'hanno
più che sta dietro divano siamo soli
poco demonio
[Musica]
che a vacca
no no luca
forse li devo al cavallo chi è questo ma
chi è quello basato riuscito ma cos'era
quello ma cos'era quella lì forse devo
far far casino in modo che ali e gli
ammassi capito forse devo fare quello
ma dove cazzo è uscito quello scusate
d'acqua e uscì come ha fatto uscire un
tipo da qua come ho fatto fino a
seriamente come ha fatto uscire un tipo
di qua codice di scelta deve mica è
uscito quel tipo ii è uscito è uscito un
tipo di qua non ha senso ci troviamo
non possiamo fare amicizia e basta
ce la faremo ha promesso
non è che c'è una botola che non vedo
famiglia la gente mi vede dai piani di
sopra difficilissimo
di non pensare di sentirlo nelle pareti
no ragazzo ha creato da dove minchia sei
entrato da dove minchia entra
ma da dove ma non c'è nessuno dietro di
me ma da dove è entrato raga non ci non
c'ero ma sono mica scemo
cioè si guarda qua qua e dove vado qui
qui è dove dove sono tutta la zona non
c'è nessuno sa dove amy chiesto tizio
and aliens sto tizio esce dai con totti
se dal soffitto come cazzo è possibile
da dove esce dato che uscito giuro è in
poi è assurdo assurdo perché non hanno
senso
c'è un tizio che esce dando da dove non
l'acqua tipo
però non ho capito da dove mi ci arriva
ecco lì ad aspettare di morire stato è
arrivato questo papa dove è arrivato
questo non capisco
giuro da dove minchia uscito da dove da
non ci sono porte non c'era prima e
comparso dal niente un po nei 16mi che è
uscita da una porta non c'è niente o
d'acqua ha però mica mi fa strano di tdt
ci dette blu
io non so se devo perché qua e un'altra
zona devo tornare qua
forse dovevo dovevo tornare cioè
affanculo va minchia ho capito non devo
chiedermi consigli non siete buoni non
siete buoni tutti parlavano di condotti
sali le scale salire ma che scala che
quando nicchia la navetta bastava che
dicesse la navetta che sia quanto prima
era che non se manco i consigli manco
quelli una cosa ho chiesto manco quella
[Musica]
cercando di capire se un fatto veramente
giusto se devo richiamare la navetta
stai tornando indietro no non sto
tornando indietro questa non è una cosa
di prima sta andando avanti ma devo
andare avanti non è qui va bene pietro è
vero ci avete ragione o che erano niente
ho sbagliato io ok forse siete buoni a
dare consigli sono io che non sono buone
a seguirli
e vabbè
però qualcuno mi deve spiegare
cercando di capire come si fa da tutti
quei con momenti che mi arrivano ma non
ce n'è e mezzo che mi dia una mano seria
mezzo che mi chiamavano serie devo
distrarli ci sono sono insuperabili quei
tizi disse ti vedono ci sparano memoria
prescindere
devo prenderla sopra a sprangate il tipo
prendergli l'arma è vero bravo questo un
ottimo consiglio vediamo prendo
sprangate letizia vediamo dice il tizio
quello ok alla prova prova a prenderla
sprangata il tizio questo che c'è qua
dietro di pio llarme ammazzo la gente is
he is incazzo però modo per sta al tipo
era dietro prima moglie sparito lo fissa
di qua ovviamente
io avevo mille medici sono spariti ma se
mi avesse visto
dov'è il tipo di prima raga parte che
non so come prenderlo sprangate perché
ok equipaggiava il razzo il tipo sta
pattugliando dov'è dove è finito
sparisce boh
era un ape l'idea quella di ammazzarlo
una verità quella di ammazzarlo valida
pisa però non lo trovo più
ma secondo me devo andare di qua e là
solo che non so come arrivarci girati
che ti costa girati ok
ma sono nasco posto qui
brauer auto sisci cos'è ma [ __ ]
come hai fatto a vedermi
infattibile infattibile praga non siete
buoni a dare mezzo consiglio 0 proprio
per sassi ministro devo andare via con
ricordi non ti spara
vabbè inviti gas
basta fammi vedere un walk through
consiglio chiesto come l'avete saputo da
white through alien isole shaun isole
scholl vengo qua ogni volta c'è bisogno
di consigli guardo qua non guardo voi
non siete capaci e darli
vogliamo
guardo gente veramente lenta giocare sto
gioco vero
qua non si capisce un cazzo
ma allora parlò di da come si può
leggere file
e a causa
vorrei evitare queste pause ma non siete
buoni a dare consigli devo fare devo
guardare come fa andare avanti
stiamo bloccando
sì però la gente che ci gioca non ha la
gente che spara capito non vale
non capisco lega non ho capito
d'altra gente non sa non sa come ho io
la gente che mi kimi chi mi cerca il
pulsante di emergenza non serve a niente
sarei per chiudere la porta e vasto
serve a nulla
il razzo non serve neanche quello però
va bene ma neanche curva altro perché
quattro non sa non c'è la gente che fa
brucia sta gente qui ma non le persone
non ci sono persone parte che il razzo
non serve a iniziare per distrarre ali e
non anche per la gente non serve per
distrarre questi sì vabbè se quasi come
con mongoloidi si muovono cosa
forse serve veramente al largo minchia
che porta gli ho dato in faccia a
vengano se la merita forse veramente
devo usare il razzo cavolo strano però
mi fa strano che il razzo se ci sono nei
mongoloidi serio per gli arabi la prova
prova usarlo vediamo se riesco a di
lanciare a plazzo usano come si lancia
li bacio
mi chiaramente ragazzi ma vero ma non è
vero ma non ci credo sono dei mongoloidi
così sono tutti intorno al razzo ma
seriously ma dai ma lui ma non è vero
non ci credo ma sono scarsi come la
morte bastava lanciare un razzo ma no mi
chiamano lavoro neanche messi in conto
sta roba c'è un razzo e troppo poco per
distrarre la gente si sentisse per
distrarre alien quindi i razzi sono per
distrarre la gente bene ottimo era
intuitivo non lo avrei mai pensato cioè
nel senso
pensavo fossero mi vedono da un
chilometro quindi ho detto po saranno
abbastanza intelligenti da capire che un
razzo e lo ha lanciato c'è ho lanciato
qualcuno storage
evidentemente no la psi
come se ci si sporge
una beffa culo e mi sa che la pace non
ho quindi da una botta in faccia a c'ero
quasi sono quasi vabbè comunque il razzo
il razzo la risposta non lo sapevo ma
perché non pensavo fosse il razzo del
tubo capitemi c'è uno che mi scrive una
roba mi scrive un altro non è che mi
scrivete tutti la stessa cosa e molti mi
scrivevano usala il pulsante di
emergenza cioè vi pare che questa possa
essere la soluzione
no quindi io devo ascoltare un po tutti
e molti sparano cagate io devo scegliere
la meno cagata capito dovresti ragione
di più ma porca [ __ ]
no il fatto è che io con la mia testa se
vedessimo razzo guarderei ovunque tranne
che sul razzo dai cd vincere i no sono
registrati dal palazzo che anche io
comunque tranne che sul razzo perché
dire caso l'ha lanciato qualcuno storage
speriamo che guardino milan non me direi
mica l'ha lanciato qualcuno ci ha mica è
comparso dal nulla e invece loro
evidentemente lo vedono come comparsa
nel mondo
adesso però non vi vedono che volevo
fare veloce
volevano in quella portalino veloci
veloci veloci veloce veloce veloce
veloce entrai tra la pistola vanta faq
c'è una pistola nel nulla vai vai vai
veloce veloce si è fregato hanno visto
sbattitene vai vai vai vai bene
trova un punto dove salvare un punto
deve salvare un punto di salvataggio
salvataggio salvataggio eccolo eccolo
cazzo questo volevo
ciao lido grazie alla donazione ciao
marghe
mi piace un sacco la programmazione
nuova grazie mille deve ancora partire
bene cioè siam partiti solo con le la
juve con le serie quindi ancora non è
niente però grazie ciao rachele se
volete per islanda non cerca di parlare
ogni strada possibile esempio il razzo
ok
si le ho provate tutte infatti era
l'ultimo poi abbiamo riprovato il razzo
ed era quella giusta e o salvate basta
in realtà cosa faccio qua ci sarà
qualcosa sicuro ci piace un condotto
ma non avrei mai pensato a questo tutto
tranne razzo ceraso e proprio stupido
cercato non vai lì selve di una roba un
po invece qua ma è il kit medici che ho
trovato è pronta si sono andati a farsi
[ __ ]
c'è un aspetto che devo tirare qualcosa
di qua signori e signori non l'avevo
vista soldi nello straw pagato ai
revolver selezionano nell'inventario non
ce n'è bisogno
ciao già gli sparo alle persone
torniamo gli attori facciamo il culetto
facciamo al culetto strisce prima vedere
non so se serve bene c'è speriamo serva
ad ammazzare qualcuno perché come siamo
messi questi misciano aggiornava questi
una corrente ma scusami come dispositivo
non valuto sono entrato di qua come
dispositivo non valido come faccio a
salire ci sono entrato da lì
lo stesso avanti di qua chiuso per
chiuso tutto più para sulla mappa dc
sulla mappa qua cercano la cellula dati
nella sala supporto tecnico va bene va
bene va bene e ho te sarà l'accesso
figurati materia sky mi piace qualcosa
eccola qua c'è una tessera di socio se
ti perdi un chip per di tutto
posso entrare comunque questa tessera o
salve buongiorno mi sa dire dove la
gente che devo visto le persone prima
vorrei raggiungerle trovano 50 negozi o
ego si è impantanato sul punto peccato
peccato sonore fatto quasi tutto giusto
nessun dato
[Musica]
sei venuta qua per niente sei venuta qua
a morire è stato vago gesù cristo posti
nuovi
caccia piaccia ci stanno ci stanno
tracciando schiaccia tutto sistema qua
cellula dati o gesù grazie
[Musica]
mi sento iniziato difesi molto bene buon
anno a tutti indietro
l'accesso a è vero che ha disputato la
serie non mi ricordo
ma devo riconoscere ma dai non si è
piegata figata vai se fosse così facile
a schierare le cose ma non è così facile
non pensa che parla va bene va bene va
bene al istruzioni guardare
nell'inventare ma state zitti
ragazzi sono un uomo nuovo veramente
sono una donna sono una donna nuova
adesso vado a all'isolamento anno non ce
n'è bisogno c'è il condotto cosa sarà il
condotto no mi sa di no peccato ci ho
sperato
una frase sisal che alien sia con te e
con il tuo spirito amen
la corona scontro diretto di vettura
ringraziando a cristo questo è mica devo
usare
la sintonizzato con key
[Musica]
ha incontrato la mamma aliena ancora no
è meglio così anzi o disabilità
l'isolamento un tasto tra l'altro molto
bene è sempre quel da sempre invio per
nella vita del turno
stai style stop sopra se stai bellana
scuola fa niente
io non fa niente napoli
spero che faranno al di riso e sono due
io no salve
sta sbagliando per terra che schifo va
bene io me ne vado
e stato veramente bello
codemondo sgabello
mi sono accorto
[Musica]
ho urtato fortissimo uno sgabello e non
ho urtato uno sgabello come ci si sporca
in studio c'era un tasto per spots of
god e mangiato c'era un tasto per sport
suo sbaglio io
per perché ho bisogno di scorgervi per
vedere se la gente ecco google control
poi contro ti sporchi
c'è niente che via via molto bene molto
bene a posto la sentono i condotti
piquet
ci aspettiamo uno scenda di qua adesso
anche perché non sai mai dove alien sai
poi la il sensore me lo ricordo che ti
dice più o meno dove però all'inizio tu
non lo sai dove alien cioè non c'è il
sensore che ti aiuta poi ce l'avrai che
mi dicono quando lo prendi né come lo
prendi però più avanti c'è e quando non
ce l'ho io non so dove sia se ali enti
vede sei morto sei morto non puoi fare
niente
vai dal cammino die zeit sul veloce
diventiamo per moriamo di vecchiaia
maya che era tutto come mister robot tac
tac bellezza
machista pistola qua c'era pistola
va bene va bene ho visto delle cose va
bene il successo boh io non salvo dal
no ragazzi scusatemi non salvo da
veramente troppo tempo vado a salvare la
partita
vado mi sono dimenticato di salvare la
partita ho bisogno di salvarla duro sono
dimenticatissimo se non salvo la partita
io non vivo più vado a salvarlo
scusate ma che queste muoio sul cazzo
salvataggio di salvataggio di fare non
so quanti niente per qualche strano più
mi ero dimenticato non si sa mai
gli prossima linea l'inam nation che
esce il 14 giugno davvero ma dove l'hai
letto se non lo fai che la peste posso
capire tu cuffie lo faccio giuro però
non sapevo io questa cosa che che
uscisse al nuovo meno male allora che lo
faccio adesso
per ricordare quello vecchio
buttana del porca vacca o salvato easy
peasy barcolla ma non molla
ho salvato salvato tranquilli bene e non
correre neanche nei corridori a nei
corridoi adiacenti ad alien perché ti
sente comunque c'è un mondo che guarda
ho salvato da ma se cammina normale
vicente dichiara dove è uscito tra
l'altro lo corso non corriamo
penso al bug della pistola e posso della
tess razzi vecchia pista boh che
volteggiava tra l'altro a bello perché
abbiamo visto lamentazione molto caldo e
come essere inseguiti dalla nonna quando
dici che non mangi tutta la pasta forse
anche peggio non peggio no però va messa
pistola e wow è un quadro sta pistola un
dipinto acilia riciclaggio ricchezza ma
in realtà non interessa sinceramente
esce così
richiedi che non è il momento
ap storia bellissima
io andrei accovacciato come la morte
molto bene non so dove sia quello monet
penso spero prego che sia un punto
dov'ero io prima in modo tale che adesso
rischia entra qua devo entrare no
perfetto
se cammini normale dissente
allora non cammino normale grazie a
questi sono i consigli che che sono ben
accetti maledizione vai entra entra
vince qua
l'ho sentito vicinissimo ti chiudi
chiuri a porta a porta a porta troyer
aqua lo sentivo era qua giuro giuro su
dio era quadro vicinissimo minchia che
brutto avvio bat forse un secondo in più
non mi salvava ve lo giuro
poi si scopre che è pietro ma c'è gente
ciao persone sono sono ciao ma è un
robot ue ci sono i robot i migliori
qualcuno va bene ma no non c'è la sedia
annuncia la sedia
è vero che questi capo diventano pure
stronzi e ri cablaggio mi spiegate che
cosa minchia serve ad aprire porte che
non sono utili però la storia sono porte
che tengono solo oggetti in per
l'inventario
questa è la mia ipotesi sembra
confermate perché non ho capito cosa
salvo poi c'è gente lì c'è gente sono
robot in realtà però
attento ai robot che ti picchiano non se
li picchiano prima io una donna
riservata di piazza non vi rendete conto
di cosa succede da bollo tutto sotto
controllo per la sua registrazione e
quasi completa lascia stare troverà la
strada da sola non glielo consiglio ma
stai zitto
solo cadeau tirare fuori lika serve solo
per gli stitici che il cablaggio e
ragione un consiglio un po più di ieri
cablaggio che chi minchia serve il
rilevatore di movimento eccolo è stato
modificato
ok questo serve per vedere
minchia no a tutto bene di cablaggio
serve per creare diversivi siete sicuri
sofio ragazzi mille la donazione
portello disabilitato questi qua servono
anche per aprire le porte o no accesso
per te la vedi che serve proprio da
forte sediamo
mi bueno
ma le docce sto male fa che funzionino
per il live e mi ricordavo che le donne
meno io mi ricordavo che nel all'inizio
originale mi ero fatto la doccia però
qua non l'ho fatta cavolo peccato e
saremo qua c'è la batteria si spreca le
stesse batterie del della torcia
sembrate di diverse non salvare la
partita
non so dove il corso presso parma fa
sapere 0 a sentono antiqua a noi c'è un
altro posto qua è pieno di sia android
io devo combattere la mia nave mi piace
effettuato
deve esserci un altro modo band è se c'è
un condotto
mi chiamo il filone cosa dvd di bagagli
ah no mi dava un bagaglio bene non usa
batteria il rilevatore davvero a bada
bene sto a minchia questo è diverso tra
l'altro sicuramente
altri cablaggio sarebbero trovare per
bloccare alien quando cielo dietro sky
mi riconosci cv ascoltami
dobbiamo ristabilire le comunicazioni a
lungo raggio sta indietro
ti avviso americani
minchia che botta non gli fa niente la
pistola non so se l'hai capito
porca [ __ ] la pistola non serve ad onna
che botta presa l'altro quelli lì
sevastopol hanno fatto i robot killer
non ce ne hanno fatti apposta per
picchiare la gente va beh
accedere ascensore non farti individuare
quella una telecamera in maniera si sa
salvataggio salvataggi
che ne dice tipo qua devo arrivare qua
bene devo arrivare lì sicuro il problema
arrivarci però vabbè questi mi sentono
se cammino se faccio così legge
se proiettato il video bene vai bene
forse o disabilità con la telecamera non
ne sono sicuro forse devo andare lì
o devo andare dove sto tizio o non ho
capito
intanto vediamo senso riuscito a fare
qualcosa così probabile molto bene
grande cazzo chiama ascensore posso
entrare nel che per quelli che hanno le
chiavi le cose quindi c'è ansia capito
dai veloce porca vacca veloce veloce
beh dai st parte l'ho fatta bene liscia
liscia
meno male perché non avevo salvato la
partita dove ritornare tutti i miei
ciao alessandra ciao paolo e non l'ho
ancora salvata quindi se muoio sono
cazzi uguali però ok per ucciderli
definire al latte senso cui piace ma non
muoiono studi che mi pare grazie a gesù
cristo arrivo arrivo arrivo
se n'è più di romo draga
me la ricordo st stanza mi ricordo anche
st botola non sa per quale motivo
mi hanno visto lo devo andare
contatta la verlaine equa che devo
contattarla
scusami in questo punto ci sono sopra
sentiamo qua sotto qua sotto
sicuro vado in un punto abbastanza utile
mi ricordo che me la ricordo st stanza
strano non so perché mi ricordo solo
questa stanza forse perché ci torniamo
più volte
ops
a bordo lavorano insieme crea una
stazione sarà scopo la più sicura in
meglio collegata
non so dove dovrei cliccare
forse dove sta lui non lo so ma qua non
c'è neanche una porta molto male
tre colpi alla testa per uscire i robot
ma siete pazzi torcia jonico per me
cojoni prime non mi muovo per un nuovo
veloce perché voglio vedere se ne
prendono voglio vedere cosa succede se
mi beccano o mappa aggiornata
poi c'è una porta vedi che c'era una
porta i seguono i robot ma non fa niente
perché volevo vedere come funzionava
destra
è veloce però che segue la gente veloce
veloce veloce velo sulla sua veloce
porca [ __ ] malizia che male lei entrata
ma all'ami screanzato schifoso aia
compatta lì ci sarà emergenza non c'è
dai va bene non fa niente
ci ho provato almeno un soft so cosa
dove fare dopo bene non sono tanto forti
pensavo fossero più forti però non non
li batte cioè meter gli spari quanto
vuoi serve solo debilitarlo il secondo
non serve a niente dicono sono fatti di
titanio
ecco
azioni esperte disabilitate per ordine
di aborto non collegata per le comuni
allena da solo
e quindi la più vitale no
ci deve essere qualcuno dopo per
comprare sul votazione
è vista che l'altro terminare da quello
che c'era sotto sbaglio
minchia arrivando un tizio speronari di
esattamente qui
apollo peccato metà lavorato insieme per
una mia mente morto forti sicuramente
bianco
leggo palle
vai la prima volta che seriamente mi
saluta un armadietto la prima
non posso aiutarla 6 bricolo
va beh
ma come come come ha fatto o mi chiamo
fenomeno
[Musica]
levati levati
è questa il computer qual è il terminale
rega
ok ok quindi e questo vi perdono le mie
tracce senza patente
all
le distanze
dai togliti
l'uomo sempre di qua un buono
effetto dei cieli pare che pure contro i
robot che sbatte ogni traccia
no che palle
dai dai dai dai veleni veloce nessuno se
lo faccio la faccia bene guarda faq
mille anni raga dove siete
pensiamo alla stazione vicino al centro
medico
ok siamo s school mimica se non è sicuro
a sic sono ha sigillato questo posto i
suoi android ivan incir ad uccidere
gente è impossibile contro i protocolli
programmazione l'intesa la section la
pensa diversamente riguarda i sintetici
e c'è qualcos'altro
una creatura grossa e letale problemi
aspetta una creatura una forma di vita
di tipo sconosciuto un organismo alieno
estremamente preferita dai rottami
l'hanno colpita nell'attraversamento non
posso muoverla servono attrezzature
sanitarie e dobbiamo trattare la ferita
è ok
vengo da voi ok vivendo una lametta
il problema è che la navetta cosa come
in chi ha la prende
amici è andata e dall'altro è scattato
pure allarme quindi devo scappare dai
pizzi ottimo vabbè
minchia conta gente sta arrivando porca
vacca pieno
io non ho capito se sti computer list
accendendo perché mi servono
effettivamente uno strano una sega prima
è servito a qualcosa solo primo cristina
corrente il cablaggio serve a questo
[Musica]
e vedi che servizio sul serio e stavolta
non edizioni non ho capito sta roba da
di cablaggio vi farà perdere qualche
tipo ora di tempo perché ora è
effettivamente funzionato
non so come se si aprisse st porta
[ __ ]
questi qua sono anche abbastanza lenti
però che sono stati
che palle
corri corri ragazzi
quando uno studente dopo che alcuni lo
fanno sconti a nessuno preso molto bene
e vado si sta ragazza
let's golf
qui
ti prego fa che succeda qualcosa ma che
si gira qualcosa perché ne sono la più
equa no credo
la [ __ ] e si è sì è sì è sì è sì l'ho
schiacciare quello immagino non puoi
chiudere forzatamente la porta non deve
schiacciare questo è calcolato col ci
avevo creduto
sono riuscito veramente a scappare
ricchia non mi riuscirà mai più nella
vita questa cosa che ho appena fatto ve
lo dico io sono schiacciati devo andare
indietro
vabbè torno indietro si sa mai poi
magari torno ritorna indietro almeno
melis ottantina le palle suscita fare
tre yacht non so come sono vicini è vero
ma neanche per sbaglio
5 milioni di iscritti al 2000 spettatori
di domande me le farei tipo che sei nato
stupido non sei leggere delle iscrizioni
per uccidere i robot non serviva la
spranga di ferro
la spranga in ferro questa che scendono
come no no no no no ecco era erano già
tanto erano erano già erano già tanto
tre colpi in testa figure e secondo me
ero arrivato semplicemente al punto ma
non dovevo avere gente che mi seguiva
non devo avere il solo gente che mi
segue che non è difficile realtà mi sono
fatto beccare come un pollo
[Musica]
no
lei
corri corri sbattere mi segua la prego
è il papa
in questa volta sono stato molto più
veloce di così
forse devo andare dalla parte opposta si
è aperta speriamo perché sono solo nel
mio letto qui che si aperta al mese
perdermi aspetta non sia aperta
beh ci dovrebbe essere scritto domandare
quale fugge attraverso attraversando la
sigla comunication ha quindi dovevo
tornare veramente indietro ma che
mongolo era giusto il loro veramente
tornare dietro avevo avevo schiacciato
aveva schiacciato qua per sbaglio un
deficiente aveva schiacciato per sbaglio
cioè invece per levarmi in italia invece
dove veramente tornare indietro che
scemo ok allora aveva già fuggiamo il
vento i condotti con la bava li si può
andare
ok quindi vado finché non un cuore non
mi dice fermati scaglioni
ma lasciamoli perfetto perfetto
minchia che avanza se faccio piano
magari non mi center che sporca 38
perché non chiedermi di sicurezza
dominio non è vero
c'era pure alien prova bay e già mi sono
staccato l'audio sentite se mi chiami
già già hero ero concentratissimo su sti
qui mica è spuntato ali e non me lo
aspettavo mai
minchia orribile non me lo aspettavo
assolutamente alien
non me lo aspettavo mai alien porca
[ __ ] aspettano la nostra figlia lo
pigliano pigliano pigliano in irpinia
rovigliano è però si stronzo e non è
capito mi ha pure lui via via dal
condotto che schifo
ma no dai
ma dai ma dai ma non è possibile ma
cristo ce l'ha
ce l'ha con me perché con me va lui non
lo figli e li che fa si muove in tutto
scemo ma dai ma che palle
ce l'ha con me rai il condotto di dare
limitiamo capire però mi calai è quindi
il primo no e nel secondo però facciamo
piano che sono c in groppa va beh come
faccio dove entrare nella porta anche
cosa mi fa beep beep
minchia vero non l'ho visto
si è spostato miccichè brutta storia
rega i condotti che sbavano li invidio e
vito proprio tutti condotti
possibilmente va bene evitiamo i
condotti tutti chi vi chiama di tutti
gli altri non vengono presi dal sì
perché non sono esseri viventi giusto
perché si chiama fare stealth ma io lo
conosco queste terminologie non le
conosco io chiamai schiava si chiama
saper giocare ai videogiochi in realtà
più che farsene
comunque credo che non ce l'ha fatta
tanto loro robot è sparito
no equa per rompermi le palle
live chiude alle undici e mezza tutto
quello che riesco a fare entro le 11 e
mezza
va bene
jobs
da
aspetta di capire
dai ci credo che ci credo ci credo coro
gli deriva fi
sì credo sì credo ci credo ci che oggi
credo ci credo ci credo ci credo ci
credo
manca niente
tra i cadetti si schiaccia pezzi di culo
ci ho creduto mamma mia radio perché ali
non vede sente gli odori ok quindi baba
bastava ricoprirsi di pro di chanel o
ricoprire di chanel globe per il non
avete parlato riesce bene qua non penso
ci sia l'impegno di corvo ce né c'è il
nuovo per terra tifoso di un live ma va
a cagare
ecco bravo ma no c'è alien fucazza non
c'è però devo lorenz ho letto il mio
nome
lawrence system bene
qua non penso chadaj siamo le navette
semmai sinti rumori speck e salvo
una minchia che cagà e ti va bene che
non ti ho sparato in faccia la gente che
c'è qua prego prego andate divertite
bravi bravi
esattamente quello che avrei fatto fossi
in voi sono riusciti tranquilli tutti
scemi are only corrono o
raggiungi la torre è giusto la torre di
qua mi chiedevo prendere 26 navette
comunque laga veramente non ho vita io
sono morto e non capisco in medikit dove
si trovino
non so dove si trovi
di qua no giusto
sì
un tana tutta la [ __ ] che caga
[ __ ] che caga [ __ ] che caga
montana che caga [ __ ] che cambia non
me lo aspettavo mai mai me lo aspettavo
mai non me lo aspettavo
mai ori bile
porca vacca orribile non me lo aspettavo
ma io ho preso la navetta cristo come fa
essere lì ma come fa come è possibile
come come levatevi dalle palle ora che
corrono ad essere che corrono cosa
riguarda ma fare o no vabbè vabbè vabbè
lasciamo verde via via con parte non
parte
cosa fate
non parte giustizia a caso boh
è comunque non ho capito perché qua c'e
ali non ho capito
va beh
apriti però ma come può essere qua ma
sera di di la prima persona veramente
smetto di famiglia e dove vado fermo
ascoli
mi chiara che mi sono messo nascosti
simo c'è qua anzi per dietro le scatole
qui è impossibile mi vedo cioè non so
neanche da dove scelto pensate
non c'è
il quale da mettere in angolo
bene
e che a ogni volta iscritto né parte c'è
un
sì prima ho fatto rumore è certo ma non
pensavo ci fosse ho preso una navetta
cazzo
[Musica]
pensavo non ci fosse proprio che anche
adesso in un dio correrei perché minchia
come fa a essere qua c'è impossibile ok
ale ore si è parlato luciano conti
ciao amici sono amico io aspetto che
salvo non c'è la partita
ciao sono io sono tranquillo come sta ha
bisogno di cure
il centro medico è qui vicino ma non
volevo lasciarlo solo
ma mica come sede prossima regata
cercherò di riparare l'amplificatore
posso sparagli interno sequestrate via
tura salta fuori e siamo morti
vabbè c'è un coso per salvare la partita
da buy in faccia a quel lesbico va bene
a lesbico
ma c'è quello che mi parla la telecamera
ciao c'è un tipo che mi parla non so mi
ricordo chi è però adesso mi sono messo
ricordo che c'era qualcuno mi parlava
dalle telecamere
meno male la live rimarrà sul canale
certo ma devo arrivare al centro medico
musi curiamo taylor il problema è che
non so dove sia il centro medico per ora
dico prodotto va bene e mi servirebbe un
corso per salvare zio un telefono che
dato sono telefoni cioè un telefono nei
condotti può arrivare almeno per questi
condotti e non mi ricordo se sono al
sicuro mi pare che quando mi sia mai
spuntato sbaglio
ti sei perso il crafting delle ricette
della granate del medico in che senso
ciò vuol dire che non mi posso mai
curare che cazzo vuol dire spiega mi di
amy che senza questo il reparto medico
un telefono no spiegatemi come ci sicuro
io ho un 1 di vita da 6 ore eccolo di
quello che parla ciao
devo trovare un medico una mia amica ha
bisogno di aiuto di attrezzature
sanitarie sono una tua amica ma c'è
ancora molto di sotto nel laboratorio
dell'ospedale comincia linea
va bene
ma ha quindi devo usare il condotto per
forza ok ma almeno sono stato chiaro
senza ricetta non puoi costruire meglio
che te come la prendo come le prendo le
ricette c'è quella del dl medikit come
la prendo quello kraft non aver capito
questa cosa
[Musica]
usa leva nicchia per aprire la porta
alla leva a ho sbloccato semplicemente
la porta di prima la ricetta la dovevi
prendere molto prima e vabbè non penso
che ci sia solo quella visto che non
prenderla ti preclude i medikit nel
gioco quindi ci sarà un'altra ricetta
immagino e deduco perché sono uno non la
prende e tipo la mia situazione qui ce
ne sarà un'altra
non so dove di preciso come avevo fatto
io i tempi come ci si cura
è vero ti giuro l'abbiamo capita come
come se ci si cura non ho capito
a farsi quando usare il cablaggio sapete
non c'era neanche di cablaggio di unite
che ha premiato da te l'ho fatto ma stai
calmo calmo
welcome area cani
no mi dovete spiegare come ci si cura
ragazzi una tragedia
dopo quel corridoio questo questo no
questo ok
sa che mongolo carica salvataggi inserì
finché non trovi
ma figurati se per crollano che non
vedevo trovare ci si trovano solo
all'inizio uno perde il foglio e perde
le bende per tutto il gioco ma figurati
è una stronzata
quindi devo capire come curare lo cerco
dopo cioè dopo la prossima volta
scusa ma ho trovato l'ufficio che devo
fare qua scusa a devo aprire qualcosa
possibile accedere al file non è questa
eccolo 17 02 e 17 02 intenti hanno
violato la sistemi di sicurezza quindi
deduco che ci sia alien molto bene tra
una [ __ ] buttana [ __ ]
è la porta
ragazzi è un videogioco mica in di un
videogioco fatto bene questo cioè se tu
perdi un documento non è che per di
medikit in tutto il gioco è impossibile
mino non è possibile perché ci giocano
un miliardo di persona si giochi quindi
io ad esempio non l'ho visto il
documento basta che uno non vede un
documento e per tutto il gioco non hai
medikit ma va in poi è veramente
impossibile quindi sicuro c'era un
foglio prima di ma ce ne sarà un altro
vuoi che poi perché mi verrebbe da dire
che il gioco di merda se perdi un
[ __ ] foglio non puoi curarti non lo
so
e come in call of duty e se non prendi
quell'oggetto che all'inizio non hai le
armi per tutto il gioco cazzo volti
chiede quindi non è possibile che sia
solo e se n'è andato
c'è una possibile che sia solo
all'inizio mi rifiuto di crederlo
ex
mi vede attraverso le finestre
no grazie a dio no no perché capisce
perché cambi direzione perché venga
miniera co demonio penso che avesse
visto
no no no no
no no no no no no no no la porta la
chiusura di emergenza la chiusura
d'emergenza la chiusura d'emergenza se
ci fosse arrivato un secondo prima che
sfiga che sfiga orribile se ci fossi
arrivato un secco mamma mi un secco mi
bastava se matti in cui se va bè
orribile orribile ragazza mi fermo qua
per next gen
devo capire come prendere i migliori
medici e amareggiatissimo che sfiga link
che sfiga incredibile to sorella tragga
sono contento ci sono arrivato dunque in
un bel punto però minchia che sfiga
incredibile porca trottola vabbè
comunque le cure per imparare usarle
sono solo all'inizio
sarà un gioco di merda perché vi devo
dire spero che non sia così per
l'organico che sfiga vabbè nulla raga
sono stanco sudato perché fa un caldo
veste nella mia stanza però va beh spero
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi next time
facciamo un po meglio se riesco non è
andata male tranne per strova dei
medikit che purtroppo devo capirlo
perché non ho capito del non ho capito
se però spero che vi dove si è vero che
vengono infatti pensavo mai medikit a
cosa servono in realtà perché tanto dal
jelmini scioccato quindi però servono
per l'ex per le sparatorie dai poi
vediamo
speriamo di beccarla i ragazzi spero vi
sia piaciuto ma la nota a tutti grazie
per adesso video live cosa mi piace in
topless tizia se non sapevo che si
chiede e noi ci vediamo alla prossima
vita da ragazzi